Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and some new
pics of Ben Affleck’s Batmobile just dropped.
They were taken by a random kid on instagram.
He even took on with himself sitting in the
cockpit.
So let’s take a look and see what we all
think.
If you are finding me for the first time.
I’m doing DC movie and tv videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Here’s what the pictures show, it’s has
some of the Christopher Nolan Tumbler DNA
in it, but it looks a lot more like the Batmobile
from the Arkham Knight game.
Slightly less fortified but much more aggressive
and agile looking than the christopher nolan
version.
The story of the movie supposedly takes a
lot from Frank Miller’s Dark Knight Returns,
so not going with the old school Bat-Tank
is a big departure.
This feels much more modern.
The culture today is just shrinking cars down.
Frank Miller’s version was designed for
all out open war.
This one feels more like a knife.
One of the big problems with the Tumbler was
it had a hard time with corners just because
of those massive tires.
Does anyone remember the Michael Keaton batmobile
from Batman Returns?
And how it used the grappling hook to swing
around tight corners.
Physics, we don’t need no stinkin’ physics.
I am of the opinion that this batmobile, thus
far looks the closest to something you might
actually see driving around today.
Unless you count Adam West’s batmobile.
Which was also a slightly modified car.
Not a slightly modified assault tank.
Just for fun let’s look at all the most
popular Batmobiles.
If you include all the comics, movies, tv
shows and video games.
There have been almost 300 different variations
on the car.
But that number includes a lot of minor changes.
So here’s all the major versions:
There was the first one, it was a Red Sedan
and was just called “his car”.
There wasn’t anything special about it.
It debuted in Detective Comics #27.
The started calling it the Batmobile in Issue
#48.
In Issue #30 they upgraded the engine, but
it wasn’t until Batman #5 in 1941 that they
made the body much sleeker, darkened the color
and added a Bat hood ornament and a fin.
Three pages after it debuted.
The joker forced it off a cliff.
But the same design of car returned in the
next issue.
I think there was a joke in the Tim Burton
Batman about Bruce Wayne having more cars
than he knew what to do with.
Then in 1944 the Batmobile was featured on
the cover of a comic for the first time in
Batman #20.
This design was so popular it became the default
Batmobile for the rest of the 1940s.
Then of course was the 1965 Adam West version.
It was made by George Barris from a Ford Futura,
which was a failed concept car that they never
put into production.
He modified it to give it the look and interior
functions.
In 1973 the Superfriends cartoon introduced
a modified version of the Adam West car.
They just straightened the lines, changed
the hood and added the batman decals on the
doors.
This was the first car to feature the yellow
batman symbol on the car.
Frank Miller introduced a full on assault
tank in his 1985 Dark Knight Returns book.
In terms of size, it is the largest batmobile
ever.
It takes up three car lanes.
The joke he makes in the story is that only
something “not from this planet can damage
it”.
Of course talking about Superman.
Then in 1989 came the Tim Burton design which
lasted through both of his films.
The body was a complete custom fab built on
a chevy V8.
The added major things like the jet turbine
but kept some of the 1930s design with the
tail fins.
They modified the Tim Burton design slightly
for Batman the Animated Series.
Thanks to animation being able to fudge the
laws of physics they were able to combine
a lot of different elements from previous
batmobiles to the concept.
Then in 1995 for Batman Forever they modified
the Tim Burton design to make it look like
it actually had ribs, added lighting highlights,
a much smaller cockpit more gadgetry inside
and a much larger fin.
This was the beginning of the Joel Schumacher
era.
In Batman and Robin a couple years later then
pushed the cockpit way back and accentuated
the grill.
Supposedly they said they wanted the car to
have a larger than life presence when it was
on screen.
Almost every panel inside and outside of the
car lit up.
In 1995 when they started the New Animated
series they completely re-did the car to make
it much simpler.
That series only ran till 1999, but the design
of this car was also used in the comics.
Then in 2005, eight years after Batman and
Robin Christopher nolan introduced the Tumbler.
A modified army vehicle made to jump canyons
and lay temporary bridges.
Throughout Nolan’s Dark Knight Trilogy they
made modifications to the design like giving
it remote control features and
the Batpod Motorcycle.
The first Arkham Asylum video game in 2009
introduced a slightly modified Tim Burton
batmobile.
The most recent revision, not counting Zack
Snyder’s batmobile is the Arkham Knight
Game.
This game isn’t going to be released till
2015 but as you can see, the design combines
a lot of the urban maneuvering features with
the assault weaponry of the tank.
Right now I still really love the Tumbler,
but my favorite Batmobile is probably going
to be the Arkham Knight one from next year.
My favorite animated one is from the Batman
the Animated Series.
Now it’s your turn, let me know, which version
of the batmobile is your favorite?
Like I said, there have been almost 300 different
versions, but when you’re a billionaire
it’s no big deal.
On a related note, don’t you think it’s
interesting that Stephen Amell doesn’t have
a Green Arrow car on Arrow.
I’m glad, I don’t think it would work
with the tone of the show and the look they’re
going for.
He has a motorcycle though.
I would like to see them joke about Felicity’s
van being their official team arrow car.
She ran over Summer Glau in it.
It would be great if they never fixed the
dent that she left and anytime someone made
fun of felicity, everyone just looked at the
dent and got quiet.
They’ve still got a lot of filming left
to do on Batman vs Superman but more and more
pictures are posting from behind the scenes.
There was an image of Jesse Eisenberg with
weird Lex Luthor hair.
It’s not a guarantee or anything, but this
might be what he looks like in the film.
Jason Momoa has all but confirmed he’s playing
aquaman too.
I don’t think I did a video about it, but
Zack Snyder called a radio station defending
the idea of Aquaman.
He wasn’t confirming the character was in
the movie, but later jason momoa wouldn’t
stop talking about how excited he was for
the movie during interviews.
So do not be surprised if he shows up.
It’s one of the worst kept secrets about
the whole thing.
I still remember him from his stargate days.
I haven’t really liked his leading roles.
Like Conan.
But I think he can do really well in an ensemble.
Right now I’m working on a new Avengers
Guardians of the Galaxy video for tonight.
There’s a lot of interesting things going
on behind the scenes in terms of contracts
with Dave Bautista’s Drax character.
So I’ll explain what’s happening in that
video.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
You should be able to click here to watch
it.
I’ll add the link as soon as the video posts
and click here to learn about all the tv shows
and movies I’m doing videos for this fall.
It’s my big fall trailer.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!